nous excuser aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui écoutés on se retrouve sur
un truc complètement nawak j'ai reçu ce
jeu par mail ou n'a en fait danser des
interfaces avec un mec au gros théo gros
tt a donc déjà en apprécient de base ce
jeu est en fait à droite on a plein de
bars qui représentent chacun un truc est
quoi la bac aux touches le bar il se
passe absolument nawak ça représente
chez pas par exemple ça peut être la
taille 2 des anges de j'en sais rien et
ça et on peut le modifier de manière
totalement abusé c'est tout simplement
un générateur de what the fuck
commençons par exemple cliquez là dessus
la semaine à frau c'est ça n'a aucun
sens mon gars de la salade derrière lui
le bon hipster de 2015 une clope une
bière un karaoké alors direz on guérit
coffin quiz quel objet a été le plus
acheté en france en 2015 ou un an
réponse un ace un oreiller un chamallow
géant un peu fondu moi j'aime bien juste
l'afro et la clope au bec voit la salle
de amer bada ce mouvement' il sait quoi
ça par exemple sus les mouvements qui
fait ça c'est un mouvement qui fait
voilà il fait une petite danse il kiffe
bon là il s'excite mauriac à 23 il a
pris beaucoup trop de drogues cet homme
arrête arrête arrête taille ne fut peut
être à temps a changé le fond space
voilà un mec qu'on a beaucoup tromperie
o il se passe quoi
ah par contre sûr mais les mouvements un
parent ça donne un truc un peu cool au
web a battu là au
fond ils n'en peuvent plus de sa vie il
veut ce tuer big big c koi
[Musique]
à cela un peu style et pipo l'album
d'accord et alors là mon gars là c'est
la taille des muscs et des différentes
parties du corps par exemple ça c'est
les la taille des gens
ça doit le quad et l'apple
excellent aokas ans quand ses jambes se
plie quand tu as un pote à la taille des
faits ce nom
mais qu'il espère défaite est
plus fort que tout et star us réunit le
plus grand toit que du monde
on dirait mais plus un coup dur et des
ailes we have band machin bon allez on
va lui mettre tes un body correct voilà
voilà ça c'est raisonnable et fasse
comme ça c'est raisonnable est ce que
c'est l'aèdes j'dis times watts quand il
est étonné du gars comme ça le mec école
est extrêmement étonné
quoi j'ai pas tout compris ça c'est
glauque aux assauts de ses dents qui
volent father ce geste au latin il est
était la taille des tétées bordel on en
parle depuis le début voilà pourquoi
avoir des airbags qu on peut avoir des
gros tu étais et qu'on peut s'étouffer
dans ces grosses têtes aux mêmes
machines sexuelle du futur le mec c'est
horrible général abily tio alors ça
c'est fait tu feras tu es là jennifer
lawrence qui passe derrière toi
c'est faux en fait c'était poutine mail
au
wat attend avec sur les plots 400 sont
pas là qu'on voit ses pieds phoque je
quitte ce corps comme ça il est parfait
comme ça à temps et si on le fait on
s'éveille non mais mon garage et le
rappeur de cauchemar la strate bernois
de
sortir de l'enfer on était un mec du
pierre qui est en train d'exploser
michael maass ouah on peut quand même
voir un oeil ou un gros tu étais on sait
pas garder on dira d'origami de doter un
mec a fait un bateau en papier quoi tu
mets dans l'évier comme ça c'est drôle
théo parfait comme ça il est parfait on
ira trèfle à quatre feuilles mongai
porte chance là c'est moi le matin quand
je suis très fatigué je me lève et c'est
le drame
[Musique]
d'hier et quelques allumés une main aux
fesses dans la rue alors qu'il s'attend
ce match c'est la vache en plus tu as ça
fait carrément peur que jamais les
fesses de quelqu'un par exemple imaginer
quelqu'un qui a je ne sais pas c'est
fait cela c'est ta copine by the who
c'est une statue on s'en fout tu as
envie de toucher et là tu touches et tu
vois de 12,7 tête qui s'agrandit comme
ça au bas de la personne est très étonné
et d'un coup qu'est ce que tu viens de
faire bâtard ça n'a aucun sens on
regrette alors la belle journée d'été
qui sont dans la bouche quoi mais qu'on
dirait qu'on se reformant pacman comment
devenir pac man man en ce mélange
incroyable mon gars regardez on dirait
qu'on devient crap quoi et si tu mets de
la chantilly sur le crabe
générés aléatoirement mec en cliquant là
dessus
non mais quand tu reviens du paintball
et à prix très très cher enfin tu t'es
pris deux bombes nucléaires de peinture
à ce stade
what's hot et le windows quand ça bug
olalalala regard il est génial s'il a
d'autres créatures mais qu'on dit une
créature de tim burton dont l enfer les
gens dans sa poche tel absents blé leur
énergie vont petit à petit oui j'ai bien
on dirait moi le giro j'ai mon [ __ ] de
bach
[Musique]
en fait quand il fait ça il devient une
huître non il savourait peu une mon gars
ça doit de regarder tentacules de merde
là m'ont dit on est en train de créer le
monstre ultime [ __ ] de choristes ont
trouvé un on dirait juste dtt sur pattes
qui danse il a l'air inoffensif et
tellement doux bordel audiard un petit
carnet je ne suis pas un petit scarabée
[Musique]
sur verybag c'est officiellement le jeu
le plus beau de fuck en effet sur cette
chaîne youtube en quatre ans on
s'applaudit c'est juste un site web ça
se télécharge pas donc si vous avez une
heure de perm est un pc ce qui
n'arrivera jamais à l'époque savez quoi
faire vous devez tester par vous même
parce que je me suis sentie développeurs
de jeux pendant une seconde et j'ai
adoré faire absolument n'importe quoi il
ce personnage 1 74m pour cette vidéo
vers ça vous regarde et portez vous bien
je demande pis
[Musique]